good morning John it's Thursday October
9th October 9th is officially less than
one week until your book comes out and
unless you live in certain select areas
where apparently time is transported
forward let me talk a little bit about
Paper Towns and what's going on with it
right now it seems as if some bookstores
are not exactly paying attention to the
rules that were set for the release of
my brother John's book so I'm sure many
of you know that if you pre-ordered
Paper Towns on burns and Noble you
actually received that book well in
advance of two weeks early if book
stores sold like Harry Potter a week
early JK Rowling would hire an army of
Harry Potter mercenaries and they would
go and kill Barnes Noble with special
wands that shoot bullets out of them and
are called ak-47s now of course I am in
no way I'm getting the destruction of
Barnes & Noble I think the very great
store but I am a little bit upset it
feels kind of like that disrespecting my
brother you know Oh October 16th okay
well yeah man we'll sell it when we want
to so I'm actually pretty excited for
the nerdfighters who got their books
early because that's sort of this
awesome prize you get for pre-ordering
Jon's book thank you very much for doing
that but for those of you who order the
book from Amazon where they didn't ship
the book out early you can feel good
because Amazon is playing this game the
way that Jon's publishing company asked
them to play it if you are jonesing for
some John Green this is available right
freaking now John Green Top Billing over
of Laureen Johnson and Lauren Myracle
done I don't know how you manage that
with those two much better selling
authors than you are it does occur to me
that it's alphabetical and you got this
lame-ass dirty picture on the back to
generally tell him the YouTube video but
John looks like he has just taken a bath
in dirt cakes
he needs a wash it mom's not gonna be
happy I just started reading Maureen's
which is the first in the book unlike on
the cover and you are correct that means
that it's time for some Hank read fast
talk and book readin the Jubilee
expressed by Maureen Johnson chapter 1
it was the night before Christmas so
it'll be more precisely with the
afternoon before Christmas before I take
him to the beating heart of the action
let's get one thing out of the way and
her from experience that if this comes
up later it will distract you so much
that you won't be there to concentrate
on anything I tell you my name is
Jubilee doogal take a moment let it sink
in see when you get up front it's not
too bad now watch and I was halfway
through telling you some long story can
like I'm about to be and I dropped that
one on you by the
my name is Julie you wouldn't know what
to do next I realized you will lose a
bit of a stripper name you probably
think that I've heard the call of the
pole but no if you saw me you'd get the
idea pretty quickly that I'm not a
stripper
I think I have a little black Bob you
wear glasses at the time contacts the
other I'm 16 I sang in choir and I
attend mathletes events I play field
hockey which lacks the undulated maybe
old grace that is the stripper stock and
trade I have the problem with strippers
in case there are any strippers eating
this and does not one major concern
stripper twice as the latex I think
latex is probably bad for your skin
because it doesn't allow it to breathe
my objection is that Jubilee isn't a
name itself kind of party no one knows
what kind of party have you ever heard
of someone throwing a Jubilee and if you
did would you go cuz I wouldn't it
sounds like something where you have to
have a large inflatable object put up
bumping and make a complicated plan for
trash disposal come to think of it it
might actually be interchangeable with
hoedown Oh Maureen I can't imagine
anyone being able to resist this book
after having heard that I have to admit
that else or the first chapter of John's
and it is also a fantastically funny and
for those of you who made spoon hands
and spoon fingers videos most of you
don't know what I'm talking about
thank you very much you will be
receiving your mp3 soon it has been
recorded and will be in your inbox
shortly and for those of you who don't
know what I'm talking about
you will next week boom so yes less than
a week away from Paper Towns that it
snow is out now we will be in New York
City for the launch event gonna RSVP
down on Facebook through Paper Towns
calm and I hope to see many of you there
and other places across the United
States through the month of November and
for those of you who I can't see you're
seeing me now and I see you I can feel
you on the other sky by the camera my
auto Petroff what a pal I don't know why
this camera does that we were having a
moment in an auto power off to me one
time additionally you might have seen
that John and I are right now on the
front page of YouTube we did a video
with the folks at politico.com and
response to the most recent presidential
debate this video is a response to that
video you should check it out it's
awesome let us all for today John I will
see you tomorrow with you